hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast I am sitting this morning with
Robert Wright who is the author of
non-zero
um the moral animal and uh other books
Robert what else have you written
most recently why Buddhism is true
before that the evolution of God in my
first book was called three scientists
and their gods
there you go
um so you and I are meeting this morning
in part because you uh you raised my
hackles with a tweet that you made
effectively uh in not such subtle terms
suggesting that I might have lost my
marbles
does that um
actually it's interesting that you
should put it that way
first of all I'm glad I'm glad mission
accomplished I got your attention I I
noticed that you know so I tweeted about
a tweet that featured a video segment of
of your show
uh I might as well I'll just read the
tweet and then we can get to the
interpretation of because I know that
you and Heather disagreed about the
interpretation
and I think she was a little closer to
the to to my intention but anyway
uh it's my tweet says so Brett Weinstein
is seriously suggesting that Democrats
have maintained the vaccine mandate for
the military because their goal is quote
degrading military Readiness unquote in
the past I've argued that some of his
crazy sounding theories aren't
completely crazy I'm not arguing that
now and uh the disagreement between you
and Heather is whether I I was saying
now I'm arguing he's Brett is completely
crazy Heather said well maybe he's just
saying this one thing you said was crazy
actually that she's closer to right in
fact if you look at my tweet I think
you'll find it's like 219 characters
long if I recall correctly I'd first
written I'm not arguing that in this
case didn't fit
and I changed it in this case to now now
that said I should say that you know I
don't listen to your podcast regularly
I'm sure you don't listen to mine
regularly so neither of us needs to take
offense at that but I'm not familiar
enough with your output to uh pronounce
on the General State of your mental
health uh so I'm not I'm not going to
start off with a clean bill of health I
guess I'm not going to start off with
any bill of health um I I do think
this this what you said in this show and
I listened to I went back and listened
to the whole thing after this tweet
um along with some
other positions you've taken and the way
you've taken them suggests that uh
you're not viewing some things with as
much balance as maybe you're capable of
in some sense that's true of all of us
you know uh you and I know that
motivated reasoning is part of human
nature
uh uh so I'm sure I'd be subject to some
kind of critique along these lines but
today I guess I'm going to make the
critique about you and uh you're going
to uh fend it off masterfully
um well I think I'm frankly going to
fend it off easily although I believe uh
it is interesting that you intended and
I I certainly take you at your word
especially in light of the Twitter
character limit that what you had
originally written would have made very
clear that Heather's interpretation was
closer to right and that it was only
um your edit that led me to conclude
that you were drawing some sort of
global conclusion on the other hand you
are saying here that you believe that
some sort of motivated reasoning is
behind what you described uh more or
less as uncareful positions that I've
taken
um in recent memory and
I I take some exception to that because
it's when you say motivated reasoning
you are making an appeal to a very
specific process and the fact is you
know look I I respect you as a scientist
you're not trained I'm actually not a
scientist but I but I'm happy to be
called one on TV sorry don't accept it
um as I mentioned the last time we spoke
I think very highly of non-zero as as a
book it influenced me I don't care how
you've come by your scientific thinking
you clearly have and uh the fact that
you do scientific thinking at a high
level inside a discipline that I know
well uh tells me you're a scientist
whether that's training or not okay
um I'll accept the honorary degree thank
you very good
um but when you say motivated reasoning
I believe I understand my motivations
pretty well and I'm not saying that
there isn't noise in my process I'm not
saying that I uh do not you know uh
overweight certain people's opinions you
know obviously there's noise in all of
our thinking process but what I'm
motivated to do is get it right and at
this moment in history that's become
extremely difficult to do well uh in
part it's extremely difficult to do well
because we no longer have an agreed upon
set of or source of factual information
from which we proceed
we effectively have been
denied among other things a paper of
record that simply records the basic
consensus surrounding the facts and so
we are all now driven into pockets of
sense making that are isolated from each
other and your pocket is different than
mine which I understand but
the problem is I agree with that
characterization largely by the way in
our book Heather and I discussed the
danger of hyper novelty which is making
modern people sick both physically and
psychologically
two of the most common disorders are
anxiety and depression our first sponsor
mind Bloom is a leader in the treatment
of anxiety and depression using at-home
ketamine therapy
it is a combination of science-backed
medicine clinician guidance and support
for people looking to improve mental
health and increase their sense of
well-being
mind Bloom connects patients to licensed
psychiatric professionals to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience
to begin take mind Bloom's online
assessment and schedule a video consult
with a licensed clinician to determine
if mind Bloom is right for you
if approved you'll discuss your health
history and goals for mental health
treatment with your clinician to tailor
your mind Bloom regimen
mind Bloom will send you a kit in the
mail complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience
after only two sessions 87 percent of
Mind Bloom clients reported improvements
in depression and 85 percent reported
improvements in anxiety
it's time to enter the next chapter in
mental health and well-being let mind
Bloom guide you
right now mind Bloom is offering our
listeners a hundred dollars off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com
Darkhorse and use the promo code
Darkhorse at checkout
go to mindbloom.com
Darkhorse promo code Darkhorse for a
hundred dollars off your first six
session program today that's
mindbloom.com
Darkhorse promo code Darkhorse
this episode is also sponsored by
American Hartford gold
inflation is at its highest level in 40
years interest rates are skyrocketing we
are caught between runaway inflation and
a recession our retirement accounts are
in real Danger
if you want to protect your financial
future but you don't want the hassle or
risk normally associated with mining
call American Hartford gold and let them
show you how to protect your savings and
retirement accounts by diversifying your
portfolio with physical gold and silver
they make it easy but you'll need to use
your phone
all it takes to get started is a short
call and they'll have physical gold and
silver delivered right to your door or
inside your IRA or 401k
they are the highest rated firm in the
country with an A plus rating from the
Better Business Bureau and thousands of
satisfied clients
call them now they will give you up to
fifteen hundred dollars of free silver
on your first qualifying order
call American Hartford gold at
866-828-1117 that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to 998899
again that's
866-828-1117 or text Darkhorse to 998899
many shoes fit your foot like a glove
that's not a good thing
our final sponsor Vivo Barefoot knows
that
vivos are made by people people with
feet who know how to use them and their
shoes are a revelation
here at Dark Horse we love these shoes
they are Beyond comfortable the tactile
feedback from the surfaces you're
walking on is amazing and they cause no
pain at all because there are no
pressure points forcing your feet into
odd positions they're fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot but modern shoes
that are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis one in which people move
less than they might in part because
their shoes make their feet hurt
Vivo barefoot shoes are designed wide to
provide natural stability thin to enable
you to feel more and flexible to help
you build your natural strength from the
ground up
foot strength increases by 60 percent in
a matter of months just by walking
around in them
the number of people wearing Vivo
barefoots is growing once people start
wearing these shoes they don't seem to
stop
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
as well as everyday wear
they're a certified B Corp pioneering
regenerative business principles and
their Footwear is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural world so you can run wild on it
go to Vivo barefoot.com Darkhorse to get
an exclusive 20 off
additionally all new customers get a
100-day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do
that's
v-i-v-o-b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com slash
Darkhorse I have my own issues with you
know New York Times in particular I I
think the Trump era uh you know left uh
the media environment in worse shape
than it than it found it I think the
reaction to Trump
uh you know had in some ways a
corrupting effect on on some media but
go ahead well I even uh find that
description a bit troubling because
although Trump was certainly a unique
phenomenon
um the idea that it was the Trump era
that drove this it was an ERA that may
have been characterized by the oddness
of trump and everything uh that was
extreme but Trump didn't cause this I I
actually didn't say he did I didn't I
didn't attribute any responsibility
Trump the person I said the Trump era I
think or the Trump you know left the the
reaction and I said the reaction to
Trump
by the media I think had a corrupting
effect I'm not sure we want to spend a
lot of time on this
um but I should say in terms of my own
you know my own kind of credentials uh
in a certain sense although I'm very
anti-trump and I generally vote
Democratic I've been specifically
critical
um of the so-called uh resistance
uh for um the way it's reacted to Trump
and I think that has to some extent
infected the New York Times and other
media Outlets along with uh what changes
the kind of digital media and the
economy the clickbait economy and
everything
um I think that's had a bad effect I I
suspect we'd largely agree
in a generic way on this whatever our
view of the specifics I'm not I'm not
blaming uh Trump I I I I I I I uh so
that I don't think we need to get
sidetracked on that
well let me let me say this uh you know
I I'm not going to defend Trump I'm no
fan I really think uh he his temperament
was completely inconsistent with the the
office
um that said I also have been watching
both of our major parties for many
decades and I understand the
the vacuum of responsibility that Trump
was able to exploit and step into and so
I don't think of it as the Trump era I
think of it uh in more holistic terms
but nonetheless I think you're right we
don't want to get sidetracked on this
and there had been growing polarization
and so on uh for a long time there's
you're right there there were things
happening already and uh uh the you know
I would just say you know we said we
don't neither of us monitors each
other's media products but but my
newsletter the non-zero newsletter and
to some extent the non-zero podcast uh
has spent a lot of time criticizing even
recently Joe Biden characterizing Maga
Republicans uh you know indiscriminately
as a threat to the Republic so I I
really tried to be critical of both
sides uh in this context yeah there's
plenty there's plenty of room for that
in this era but what I wanted to point
to is more just the simple fact that in
the absence of let's say a paper of
record and the scientific equivalent we
are left with a sense making problem
that is
extremely fraught and so when one person
especially one evolutionary thinker
looks at something said by another
evolutionary thinker and leaps to the
conclusion that something might be off
to the point of mentally dysfunctional
that's that's significant to me and so
you know frankly Robert you pissed me
off right because okay
um in my in my opinion
the the bar I have to clear here isn't a
very high one am I sane yeah you'll find
out that I'm saying not only that but
you will find out that the hypothesis I
Advanced if you look at what I actually
said is
um well within the rational range in
light of the highly unusual historical
moment that we seem to be living in and
I will point out that
you imposed something on what I said
that wasn't there
what's more I did say I know how this
sounds before I said what it is that you
inferred I might be mentally off from so
let me
put the puzzle in the context in which I
believe it belongs
we have
a political apparatus that is behaving
in an utterly mysterious way
if you look at the policy surrounding
covid it's prevention and its treatment
what we got from all of the official
medical and epidemiological institutions
was pretty close to the inverse of the
advice we should have gotten that is to
say you would have been vastly better
off if you did the opposite of what you
were told than if you did what you were
told that's your view yeah I'm very I'm
very familiar with your view and I
suspect your your listeners are but but
go ahead if you want to elaborate well
what I want to say is look let's just
agree that whether that view is right or
wrong if it is correct it is not
consistent with a normal explanation
like incompetence an incompetent
Authority would have come up with a
garbage set of recommendations they
wouldn't have come up with the inverse
of good recommendations
that that is an unlikely place to have
landed right it's like accidentally
assembling a car yeah that's that's what
you that's the kind of thing you said in
the podcast we're talking about so can I
uh
can I respond to that please
um now first of all I'd say you know you
mentioned the environment uh we're
speaking in and what the standards uh
should be that Prevail
um I personally believe something that
you may not subscribe to but
it would it is that
especially in this environment giving
how incendiary it is if you're going to
suggest that the uh
the Executive Branch the Biden White
House and for reasons we'll get to
that's what I took you to be saying I'll
I'll quote the things you said but if
you're going to suggest that uh the
Biden Administration or powerful people
in there are enemies of the state which
I think you did
I would say that in the current
environment
maybe your standards of evidence should
be a little higher than for the average
hypothesis you just throw out there
uh because it occurs to you and and I'm
going to argue that uh this is not the
most your hypothesis there there are a
number of hypotheses that are stronger
than yours to explain what you've seen
that seem to have escaped your attention
and this is what I mean by motivated
reasoning and again we all do it I'm
just saying you did it I don't think I
did it because I don't think you've
understood my hypothesis well fine can I
but can I go ahead and say what I want
to say sure okay you haven't even heard
what what I'm saying all you've seen is
one tweet
well no I've just heard what you've said
about my position and it isn't my
position let me read what you said okay
and and I just want to ask whether it is
or is not the case that especially in
the environment we're in
uh uh a number of people would take this
to be a serious suggestion that there is
some kind of conspiracy in the executive
branch
uh which is run by democrats to
undermine the military Readiness of our
country so here's what you said now this
was a podcast uh featuring several
people from the armed services who uh
did not want to get vaccinated and they
were talking about the toll of the
mandatory vaccine policy it you know
some people get sidelined because they
refuse to get vaccinated and so on and
that was a big part of the toll I guess
um we've had people uh
discharged from the military it's
honorably we've had a court martial
we're talking about something Beyond
just being uh slighted right I just
meant you mean there's been a loss of
manpower
there's been a loss of Manpower and a uh
crippling decline in morale
understandably okay now this is again
this is your view and I and I want to I
kind of get the idea that you often when
you're trying to figure out what the
motivation for like a policy may be you
assume everyone shares important parts
of your view and I assure you what you
just said is not necessarily shared by
everyone right that that there is a I
mean you have had you have talked to a
series of people in the military who
share the view the reason they're on
your podcast is because they share your
view but I doubt that Joe Biden spends a
lot of time with these kinds of people
and you may see that leaves you may say
that leaves him uh like diluted or
something but I suspect it's the case
and and if his perspective is different
from yours I think that needs to be
taken into account so can I get to what
you actually said please okay
uh here a few things uh you're right uh
the policies that are so devastating
here are being Advanced most agreed most
aggressively by what I call the blue
team
the Democratic party of which I've been
a lifelong member but I can't even
recognize that party now so if you were
interested in keeping that party in
power so that it could continue to
advance bad policy but you are also
interested in degrading military
readiness
then the mandates might persist in the
military while they were withdrawn in
advance of midterm elections or
something like that in the civilian
population I hear myself saying that and
I know how it sounds on the other hand
I'm a scientist what I do is I look at
patterns and I eliminate potential
explanations based on the fact that they
don't fit until we're down to a small
number of explanations that might
underlie the pattern in this case that
is a very unfortunate process that I
think ought to alarm every American so
you seem to think this is the most
parsimonious explanation or close to
that a few other things you said in the
course same podcast
uh has something gotten into our system
that is unhooking our Readiness because
it doesn't want us ready here's another
thing it's hard to explain that pattern
by anything other than some form of
sabotage here's another thing we're
looking at something that behaves like
enemy action now I submit that anyone
who listens to this podcast and is
already inclined to not be big fans of
the Biden Administration specifically
with respect to this issue and I suspect
that description and fits a fair number
of people in your audience
could take you as suggesting that in
fact there is a conspiracy in the
executive branch to undermine our
military Readiness you don't think so
um I know exactly what error you're
making
what is it called
um let me ask you a question
do you believe that our system has a
problem with corruption
most systems have some kind of problem
with corruption I would agree I'm a fan
of there there was a were you a fan of
The Wire
I I didn't watch it no that's excellent
and there was a particular scene in
which uh an individual involved in city
government was talking to another
individual walking down the street and
their point was you have to expect a
certain amount of corruption but the
level of corruption has become obscene
and that is where we are I do not expect
a system without any corruption but the
level of corruption in our system I
would argue is utterly obscene
would you does that sound like a crazy
position to you so far
well you'd have to Define terms my main
point is that there are other
explanations for the phenomenon you're
describing okay no matter much less
incendiary and actually more plausible
you you have you have laid out your case
I haven't I haven't gotten to the other
explanations
you have laid out your case that what
I'm saying is beyond the pale now you're
not going to let me get to the
alternative explanation spread is this a
is this a scientific discussion you seem
a little defensive Robert we are having
a conversation
I would like to respond to them because
I think you so far haven't even
understood what it was that I was
putting on the table okay what were you
putting on the table
I believe we have a problem with obscene
levels of corruption in our system
I believe that covid policy reveals this
now
if you want a little historical
background I would say that before the
Clinton administration
the GOP was the party of business that
it had a business model in which
effectively it peddled influence to
wealthy mostly corporations when those
corporations wanted to do something that
was not in the interest of the public
right and there's a natural tension
between these things
you you tend to pay in order to
influence things when what you're doing
is not in the interest of those who are
being governed because you wouldn't have
to pay if it was we would just simply do
it that's what corruption is now the
Clinton Administration I believe
changed the Democratic Party
that what it did was it took up the
gop's business plan and it abandoned the
public and started serving different
corporate interests and we effectively
ended up with two corporate parties and
nobody representing the public and so
these parties both pay attention to the
public periodically when they have to
because there's an election but by and
large what they exist for is to serve
the interests of wealthy donors at the
expense of the interests of the public
that's what they do 365 days a year okay
now the problem is that there once you
have a system that is informally about
corruption
there are no good safeguards for
preventing things that you don't
anticipate from getting into that system
and so what I was suggesting was not
that Joe Biden or anyone else in the
executive branch is actively interested
in harming the country but that
something has purchased influence that
might be what do you think that thing is
well I don't know if it's not I mean but
a limited number of people can sway our
vaccine policy in the military so either
they are unwitting dupes of something
and I'm I'm waiting to hear what you
think that is uh or they are
intentionally implementing this policy
and I mentioned to say by the way that
based on the things you said the average
naive listener would think you're
suggesting uh on the basis of these
quotes that uh there are actually
conspirators in the executive branch but
if not What scenario do you have in mind
about how they become unwitting dupes
and and who is pulling the strings and
how
well let me ask you a question I mean it
seems to me why don't you ever answer my
questions and you know what what is the
answer to that question what do you have
in mind first of all Robert there is a
reason that I phrased this as a
hypothesis now the fact of it being a
hypothesis does not mean I do or do not
believe that it is the explanation it
means that it is a proposal for
something that might explain a pattern
something that makes predictions and
that it deserves to be on the table of
potential explanations okay now it
happens that I do think that this one is
plausible
but you do not have logically speaking
you don't have the right to try to get
me to fill out the picture of how this
corruption might work I don't you don't
have to State what your hypothesis is I
took it to be that there's somebody in
the executive branch corrupting our
policy intentionally you're saying no I
didn't mean that well then what did you
mean what is your hypothesis let me uh
then look we're going to get
to the approximate answer to your
question
do you think we have enemies who would
consider attacking us militarily
sure okay do you think we have enemies
that would contemplate sabotage against
us rather than attacking us militarily
do you think they have noticed that we
have a pay for play political system and
do you think they have contemplated
contemplated paying to get us to do
things that they would have a hard time
doing from the outside
now for a fact that foreign interests as
well as a number of domestic special
interests that are also corrupting uh
make donations to politicians they also
try to influence think tanks uh there's
a lot of there's a lot of Corruption of
clear thinking out there sure then what
are we disagreeing about I just want to
hear what your actual hypothesis is you
told me I was wrong wrong word you're
not even suggesting that Joe Biden or
anyone in the administration is
intentionally undermining our military
Readiness so okay who is and how are
they pulling these strings because it's
not that easy to manipulate a policy
like this so how so what do you have in
mind
again I'm not sure why you feel entitled
to demand of me in particulars that I of
course have no way of knowing the
question is are there powers out there
that have a large quality quantity of
financial capacity who might have
noticed that we have a system in which
you can pay for play who might be
feeding something into it that isn't
good for us and that the people who are
going along with this are not actively
interested in harming us but they don't
give a [ __ ] about us that's why they're
in this pay for play System
you mean the P you mean they're American
actors who don't want to harm us but
don't give a [ __ ] so they're being
bribed or something look
you know I was uh
attacked for simply paying attention to
the hunter Biden laptop story during the
last presidential election
now it turns out the laptop was what it
appeared to be and it obviously doesn't
you know
make it an open and shut case with
respect to Joe Biden's corruption but it
is certainly suggestive the things that
Hunter Biden said his presence in uh
Ukraine in a field where he was not
expert making lots of money is certainly
suggestive that what we have is an
Administration with an influence
peddling problem now the question is
do we believe that influence Peddlers
have some sort of code that they live by
where they will peddle influence to
certain people but certainly not other
people they will sell us out to some but
not others now I would guess there's
something like that but I don't know
what the code is and so when I see
in an obvious pattern of the degradation
of military Readiness and I say does the
military know that it is degrading its
own Readiness how is it conceivable that
it is okay with degrading its own
Readiness why would you take pilots in
whom you've invested millions of dollars
in training and sideline them this is a
dangerous world we build those aircraft
for a reason we train those Pilots for a
reason why would you sideline them over
a vaccine that does not prevent
transmission of a disease and that is
not necessary for a young person who is
fit enough to be a fighter pilot why
would you want me to give you some
hypotheses that have escaped your
attention you are welcome to give me
some high Powers okay
now first of all I assume you can see
why Biden might have implemented the
vaccine policy in the first place I
think your question is why didn't they
modify it Robert later you keep invoking
Biden as if he is playing an important
role in decision making well the
administration okay somebody implemented
the policy I don't want you skipping
ahead like that because the fact that
you and I sitting here I a lifelong
Democrat you as somebody who says that
you have in general voted Democrat that
you and I don't exactly know what's
President because the guy who sits in
the office is obviously at the end of
his cognitive life that's a problem that
means something is President outside of
our constitutional structure and somehow
you're okay with this you're invoking
Biden as if he's president you and I
both know there's something wrong Brett
I revised the question immediately and
said do you agree that the Biden
administration's decision which surely
you would accept as a characterization
of of orders that come down from the
Biden Administration right is that okay
can I talk like that well look you can
talk however you want but I want you you
don't just keep changing the subject no
we have been as critical I if you did
listen to my podcast you'd know the
virtually every week I say we gotta get
this guy off the ticket he's not all
there cognitively we agree on that okay
good but then then Robert why can we not
hear each other okay something is very
seriously wrong in this country if we
have a president who is not all
cognitively there and yet we're gonna
skip right into the next sentence and
say well then the administration what is
the administration what administration
would allow a senile old men to inhabit
that office with that kind of power and
not look I've said on my podcast
that Kamala Harris as much as I detest
her should be president tomorrow
that would not fill me with uh hope and
joy but whatever make me very upset but
at least it would make sense at least
there's somebody you can make a phone
call to and you can say Kamala here are
the nuclear Stakes here's what they mean
can I can I get back to the alternative
Theory
there as intentional degradation of our
military presumably they are hypotheses
but go ahead they are hypotheses you're
you're correct I was using the term I
know uh Theory colloquially
um so first of all the only reason I use
the word Biden sorry about that was I
meant that it seems to me not hard to
explain why someone who was in charge of
executive branch policy whoever that may
be would have instituted the vaccine
back when they did after all unlike you
they're I think they're fans of the VAC
they think you know it works and they
were certainly thinking that and and you
know and they wanted to bring the
pandemic under control as soon as
possible and and so one reason you would
do it is say well the military that's a
place we can order it we know that we
can we have that power we don't want to
go that far as civilians but we can at
least uh start there that might be one
reason there might be plenty but in any
event I think I assume that the main
question you're asking is once they saw
what you see is the very uh damaging
devastating Fallout of this policy why
didn't they change it that's what I have
hypotheses about okay
can I pause you there I want to hear
them but let's just notice a couple
things
the people so I accept as a plausible
hypothesis that the people who made the
decision believed that the so-called
vaccines were an important component in
controlling the pandemic I once believed
that that was likely to
there comes a point at which you can no
longer believe that because you know
that they are not effective at
controlling contraction or transmission
of the disease and you also know
that to the extent that they might be
effective at anything at all they are
extremely age stratified for risk
now at the point that you have made a
bad decision in your hypothetical world
for honorable reasons and then you have
come to understand that they are not a
useful tool in controlling the spread of
the disease that this is a population
that needs them far less than the public
and that this is having consequences for
things like Readiness you do alter the
policy and if what they had done was
said well it turns out that the you know
instead of lying which is what we've
gotten so far that oh we never set a
controlled transmission well [ __ ]
it's on video all over the place they
said it repeatedly okay if what they had
done is owned up to it and said look
this was a fast moving situation we made
the best call we could on the basis of
the information we had as the
information that we had changed it
suggested a different policy which is
why we've lifted the mandates had they
done that
I wouldn't have had a podcast that's not
what they did they still haven't done it
in fact they are doubling down on this
and they are doubling down on ignoring
the risk stratification it's not just
the military it's now children
something has gotten into our system
that is making the opposite of sense
let me say you know I think when it
became evident on Twitter that you and I
were going to have this debate slash
discussion some people got excited and
like okay you're really gonna you know
you gotta lay down the law to brat about
Ivermectin and vaccines and like I'm not
here to debate Ivermectin vaccines I
don't spend nearly as time thinking
about that that stuff as you do so
that's not going to happen now
after I lay out these hypotheses if you
would like me to explain why I quit
thinking of you as a credible Source on
this information I'd be happy to because
I remember the moment and I remember the
podcast I'd be happy to talk about that
but I'm not here to debate I'm not up on
the latest stuff uh and by the way uh I
was uh you know open-minded I think it
was on the decoding the gurus podcast
that I said I think we were talking
about you specifically I said I I think
the jury's still out on Ivermectin I've
seen a number of studies some of them
seem to suggest uh benefits you know I I
am really not I try very hard not to be
kind of a tribalistic thinker okay but
uh there was I happy to describe the the
what you said that uh that that made me
uh Gravely doubt your credibility but
first let me get through these
hypotheses okay so if the question is
uh
uh
and
and by the way you seem to be ruling out
uh
a lot of hypotheses I mean you you say
things like in this podcast uh the
absolute least pernicious explanation is
total indifference to the well-being of
service members and the Readiness of our
military force that's the least bad it
could be you know I would say that
assumes they share your view of all the
stuff we described which is the
magnitude of the Fallout the benefits of
the vaccine and and so on I just I just
wouldn't I wouldn't assume that but that
aside
let me let me mention some hypotheses
okay why wouldn't they not change a
policy a bureaucratic inertia
the military is a famously irrational
institution I was brought up in a
military family my father was a career
army officer it has been a running joke
for a long time how irrational the
military is like why are we following
this rule well the base commander 10
years ago implemented and nobody it
wasn't in anybody's particular interest
nobody thought they could get a
promotion by changing it you know it's
just like uh the military is not some
kind of lean and mean Corporation
constantly competing and looking at its
bottom line it is a classic bureaucracy
bureaucracy bureaucratic inertia happens
all the time now granted if these people
at the top of this bureaucracy shared
your views then you could say well in
not changing the policy uh you know you
are subject to certain criticisms about
your indifference to military Readiness
or something but I would contend they
don't but if you want to contest that
fine let me move on to another realize
they have their own system
completely within the military for
assessing the level of harm from
vaccines and it has the same off the
chart signal that we see in the public
varis system
the military
I mean
I don't want to get into discussion
about theirs I assume you'd agree
that one thing about theirs is that if
you're going to compare data this is the
public place that people can say I had a
symptom after a vaccine
um it's very hard to compare different
uh episodes in history
uh and because sometimes uh
the public becomes more alerted to the
possibility of reporting things to
theirs than others and now I would think
we're an all-time high but I I don't
want to argue about theirs
is a crime to report things that didn't
happen to theirs and that this question
has been studied in the majority of the
reports in veres are from medical
professionals or pharmaceutical
professionals this whole idea that this
is just some free-for-all where the
public is reporting things that didn't
happen is nonsense what's more we have
exactly the same pattern in the vares
system the European yellow card system
and the military system the military
system is completely immune to what
you're talking about and yet it shows
the same pattern okay I want to I want
to get back to this question about uh
about assessing data about the vaccine
because it is it is in that context that
I first not uh started not thinking
about you as as an especially uh
reliable source I'll explain what I mean
let me let me quickly say here are the
other hypotheses okay another one is
just
uh
they they don't want to admit error now
interestingly on the podcast of yours
with the the first one with the three
military people one of them threw that
out and and I think you missed it but
one of them said look if you're Joe
Biden you're not going to issue a press
release saying I got that one wrong
exactly exactly even if he starts
thinking he got it wrong there's a
strong incentive and we see this in all
kinds of bureaucracies to not report it
now you may say well if he shares my
view of the damage uh being done he's a
horrible person well there are a lot of
horrible politicians but that's
different from saying there's a
conspiracy to undermine our military
Readiness okay third hypothesis wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait no no no let us look at that
hypothesis fine you're telling me that
privately these people have come to
understand that what they believed
wasn't correct and there was some risk
and that they are I'm not telling you
that but go ahead you're putting that as
a proposal
if you start with your premise that they
must know that this isn't working and it
has downside if you just told me that
the average politician had run into a
case where they realized that a policy
they are identified isn't working and
asked me are they going to admit it I'll
say probably not unless it's a different
species of politicism better than yours
my hypothesis yeah is that our system is
riddled with people who are willing to
Pedal influence which means willing to
sell out the public and so they're not
especially interested in the truth of
what these things do or don't do my
guess is we would learn something
interesting if we found out how they
personally behaved with respect to
issues like coveted vaccinations but
with respect to the public I don't think
they're sitting around fretting about
whether or not these things do or do not
block transmission I think they have
higher priorities I actually agree
that's that's part of my point here you
shouldn't part a lot of your thinking
assumes the opposite they're just as
aware as Brett is of how horrible these
things are no
look my hypothesis requires them to be
indifferent and it requires something
else to be interested in
either profit making or in the case of
the thing that got me uh on your radar
again the question of military Readiness
yes there are things in the world that
are powerful that have lots of monetary
resource that are not interested in us
being militarily ready and we prefer
that we are not the question is what is
it that blocks them from buying
influence in our pay for play System
do you know
I would say it's your hypothesis and yet
I can't get you to flesh it out and tell
us
who are these players you envision how
are they manipulating the system anymore
what specific policy interventions okay
just for the sake of argument
yeah
what if China
decided that it wanted our instead of
making itself more militarily ready it
decided it would be a bargain to make us
less militarily ready and it decided to
buy influence and Advance policies that
would have that consequence without
announcing themselves as sabotage would
they be able to do it
I would think this wouldn't be one of
the first 10 things that that came to
their minds first of all they would much
rather know things about our Weapons
Systems undermine the weapon systems
um you know infect our communication
systems there's all kinds of things
this would only occur to a small number
of people what you're suggesting because
most people most people don't Universe
what Universe are those things mutually
exclusive
no but they have priorities I mean they
can't spend their money on everything
they can't focus on everything I'm just
saying this is very unlikely I've heard
of them influence in our system is
inexpensive compared to things like
building new weapon systems or investing
in the covert sabotage of weapon systems
influence in our system is cheap
why wouldn't they buy it
saying that so
wait wait wait wait wait did you just
say that of course they buy influence in
our system
yeah foreign actors try to buy influence
on our system so do domestic interests
that are can be just as corrupting yes
of course why is my suggestion that this
policy might be Advanced to reduce
military Readiness in any way indicative
of my failure of cognition well first of
all I've already listed a couple of
alternative hypotheses that are the
kinds of things we see every day
we all know they happen all the time and
so I think there are actually more
parsimonious but I want to back up and
just be clear not that mutually
exclusive
there is no place there's no place in my
entire history of public speech that I
have ever said incompetence was not
rampant it is what I've said is that it
doesn't go far enough to explain some
patterns this being one of them
let me just quote you again so if you
were interested in keeping that party in
power so that it could continue to
advance bad policy but you're also
interested in degrading military
readiness
then the mandates might persist in blah
blah so the you you're saying is a
foreign power that both wants to keep
the Democrats in power kind of
mysteriously if you look at Biden's
China policy by the way but uh but again
given the the thing you know some of the
things he's been handing downly but you
were also interested in degrading
military radius so now now I think a
reasonable person would have thought
you're talking about the Democratic
party that's clearly the most
superficiency this is why but you're
saying you don't mean that you mean a
foreign actor wants to do both of these
things keep the Democrats in power and
undermine military Readiness this is why
I go through the formalism of calling
this The Blue Team
okay the Democratic party has a history
it has things to be proud of I don't
think the thing that is currently in
power has much of a relationship with
that historical entity I mean for one
thing notice
there is essentially not a single
likable person in this party anymore
why are we stuck with Joe Biden I didn't
go that far because who who could they
put in who who could they Advance who
could win the presidency who inside the
Democratic party who could who could
beat Trump or somebody
a lot of people the trouble is they
won't nominate them ah exactly and the
people they won't nominate are leaving
yeah well this is a common party in in a
two-party system the nomination tends to
uh cater to the extremes the right and
left extremes and you wind up with
candidates who aren't necessarily well
suited to win the general but but can I
think you might have a list of
hypothesis bending over backwards to
rescue the idea that the Democratic
party is an organic entity rather than
the more parsimonious hypothesis that in
a completely pay-for-play system things
will take up that space and they will
walk around in a suit that looks like
the Democratic party doing whatever they
want for whatever reasons that they've
bought access
are also
uh
susceptible to the same kind of
influence in fact I believe they
invented this that's what I told you is
I think that Clinton took the Democratic
party and he muscled in on the racket
that the Republican Party had innovated
and that's where we're stuck we've now
got two corrupt parties now ironically
because of the role the Democratic party
is playing you now have conservatives in
the Republican Party who are actually
speaking in defense of the values that
made the country special so there is
life inside the Republican party I don't
think it's Universal I still think the
party is is corrupt Beyond rescuing but
no I think you have two teams and to
think of this as an organic political
party is a mistake at this point it's
not behaving like one it's behaving like
an influence peddling racket okay you
use the term blue team uh so I don't
know I don't know something inorganic I
don't know but anyway I'm just being
clear I think any person would have
taken you to be meaning that that that
the entity that boasts wants the
Democrats to win and wants to undermine
military Readiness and you are asserting
their their there may well be such an
entity uh is some somebody in the
executive branch that's what I thought
the only but now you're saying there is
a single there's some kind of foreign
entity that wants both I'm clear on that
so can I no I want to clean something up
okay okay I believe
a as you apparently also believe that
foreign actors will have noticed that
one thing they could do should they wish
to alter our course is to buy influence
in our system and steer okay
that is something you and I apparently
both believe is likely to be happening
so the question is is the magnitude of
that large enough to create a policy
that would for example cause us to
degrade our own military Readiness not
because it makes any sense and not
because we're being bureaucratic that
because something that has bought
influence wishes us not to be ready I
believe that is plausible at least I
believe it is not crazy which is what
you suggested in your Tweet
so far out there that given the number
of alternative hypotheses that you don't
seem to have even considered and I
haven't even gotten through my list
uh it suggests that you are you are
under the influence of highly motivated
reasons now now wait a second first of
all let us be clear what I am saying is
that it is a viable hypothesis that some
thing or more likely multiple things
that don't want us ready are acting
through the executive branch there we
have left a loophole in our system and
that they have taken advantage of that
loophole and our policy doesn't make
sense because it is not intended to
better us that's the hypothesis and you
seem to agree to all the components and
your complaint is that there are other
things that may be in play here and my
point will then be they are insufficient
to explain the level of our self-harm
yeah but again Brett your view of the
level of the self-harm is not widely
shared in the administration or in most
parts of America your podcast is this
distinct thing with its own audience
that is very distinctive in its uh
orientation and the guests you you bring
on tend to agree with you strongly I'm
just here to tell you Brett most people
out there aren't sitting there thinking
like oh my God uh you know they're
giving vaccines to fighter pilots what
if they have a heart attack most people
don't think vaccines people don't think
that right people probably that's my
point most most people probably think
it's not that weird that the CDC just uh
recommended that the states put those
same mRNA so-called vaccines on the
regular childhood vaccine schedule right
so my so my question is but but let me
but what does that matter look it
matters in the fall you are smart enough
to understand that the CDC recommending
that the states administer these
so-called vaccines to Children is not
only absurd but it is indefensible
spend much time reading up on this stuff
I'm sorry I'm here to discuss the
military race and that's the problem
Robert because let's just put it this
way this entire conversation is
unnecessary if the following thing is
true yeah the age stratification of the
risk of covid and the inverse age
stratification of the risk of the
vaccines in and of themselves mean there
is no reason in the world that we should
be recommending these things for
children what's more the fact that they
don't block transmission means it's
absurd on its face this is not
defensible logically it's not defensible
medically it's not defensible
epidemiologically so there is nothing
normal that could explain why we would
administer these things to Children
given that it's going to shorten the
lives of many of them yet we're doing it
so my point is nothing that can't
explain that is worth talking about
no so now you're asking me to explain
why vaccines are being administered in
children I'm asking you to notice that
the very same blue team which I am
saying is for some reason degrading our
military Readiness while it is a
pay-per-play system with few if any
safeguards against who buys access that
that same thing is also taking actions
that are completely inexplicable with
respect to school children well actually
I mean it look again I I don't know
enough to talk about this stuff but if
you're asking why are uh vaccine you
know if I were to be asked to accept
your premises like the vaccines they
don't do much of any good maybe they do
net harm why they be so widely uh
administered I would resort to the big
Pharma explanation okay but that's a
different question
that would be my go-to conspiracy
hypothesis but that's a different
question I thought we were here to
discuss
what you claimed on this podcast which I
think is an irresponsible thing to claim
in an era I mean ask Nancy Pelosi's
husband
how how careful we should be maybe
before declaring people enemies of the
state that's the environment we're in
and what you said certainly would give
people the impression you're suggesting
that people in in the Democratic
Administration or enemies estate now
you're telling us it's different I don't
buy I don't buy the the what you're
saying now doesn't make sense to me
either but please let me get to my next
two hypotheses
please I I don't understand what
conversation we're having I mean you you
specifically say look I don't know
enough to assess this I'm saying look
it's transparent on its face that we are
making an error as large as
administering a dangerous highly novel
treatment to children who don't need it
and won't benefit from it and for no
reason it would still not be justified
if it if it did block transmission
because it's not it's not reasonable to
harm children to save vulnerable old
people but even that explanation has
fallen by the wayside
just you Robert this is since my podcast
we are still doing this the policy
Marches On completely divorced from
reality
right right I know I know that's your
view but I didn't tweet about that part
of your view I tweeted about your claim
that someone is intentionally
undermining military Readiness via the
military vaccine policy can we get back
to that or do you just not want to
discuss it
cute
um it's not that I don't want to discuss
it it's that I do not want you framing
it in isolation as if we don't have
multiple extremely difficult to explain
things happening across many different
domains simultaneously because the point
is you can say that my hypothesis is
irresponsible and maybe even crazy if
you can isolate it but in context the
fact is we are dealing with something
that has caused our system to go
completely insane and it is not only
going insane but it is targeting
children right you have to look for an
explanation big enough to deal with that
is Pharma corruption big enough maybe
maybe I accept that as a possible
hypothesis but it is hard to understand
why a civilian Authority that can
recognize that these mandates needed to
be lifted for the public still maintains
them for the military
what is that what happened
let me just repeat that for the purposes
of the argument I'm making what you just
said
doesn't matter okay I know you believe
that for the purposes of the argument
I'm making it doesn't matter let me be
let me finish whether what you just said
is true it does matter to some extent
whether what you just said is if you
widely shared like in the Pentagon and
in the administration I'm here to tell
you it's not okay and and I just I hope
there's some logicians out there who
understand the argument I'm making and
understand that it doesn't rise or fall
on whether Brett Weinstein's view of
covet is right it rises or Falls parts
of some of the hypotheses rise or fall
on the question of whether Brett
Weinstein's view is the view that
prevails in America and you know damn
well it doesn't that's what's you know
you talk about that all the time
that is logically false because because
the hypothesis I Advanced is that you
have a pay for play system in which
people aren't paying close attention to
what is or isn't good for military
Readiness or children or the
transmission of the disease because they
have higher priorities that's not
actually the hypothesis you advances is
some of these people are paying
attention to military Readiness and want
to degrade it no that's different no you
absolutely did
no because as you read it you even
noticed as you were reading that quote
you said you in that case was a foreign
entity that might have wished to
accomplish these things acting through
the blue team right okay are you saying
somebody wants to enter my military
Readiness well look our military enemies
certainly want to undermine our military
but the point is but the point is you're
even positing uh that the administ
people Administration must be
indifferent to like good and bad
consequences depends on their accepting
your view of covet and vaccines and so
on and they don't they influence
Peddlers they're indifferent to our
well-being that's why they're selling us
out
uh
you know it it it's possible that they
are but oh my God the assertion the
assertion that the vaccine policy
unambiguously indicates that they are
Depends
Ambiguously I said hypothesis
now let me let me let me let me read you
a quote from yours
whatever it is you're talking about this
entity out there this is what you said
whatever it is is at the very least
completely indifferent to our readiness
it doesn't care for at our best or maybe
it wants us unready then you also said
the absolute least pernicious
explanation is total indifference to the
well-being of service members and the
Readiness of our military force you're
saying there is zero probability that
the people responsible for this POS this
policy are not indifferent to the
well-being of service members and
Readiness you're saying there's zero
chance that's the logical meaning of
those two statements do you agree
you are playing a shell game because I
do believe that whatever engineered the
policy has to be at least completely
indifferent that does not mean that the
people who made the policy happen are
indifferent
I do believe they are de facto
indifferent because they are corrupt
they are allowing themselves to be
steered by things that have something
other than the public Public's
well-being at their core that is what
they're doing they are doing that for
money or power or both I don't know but
they're de facto indifferent not not du
jour
I'm saying
I I never mind I I mean I I think
it's clear in your your podcast that
you're saying it must be the case they
just don't care about the well-being of
service members you said policy must be
indifferent okay that's your claim
there's no chance
that it could be anything else
whereas whereas I just it you know and
what you just said is whoever designed
the policy well come on it's very easy
to explain now you're playing
philosophical games okay if I say
that we exist and are having a
conversation am I saying there is no
chance that one of us is a brain in a
jar being fed information to see what we
will do
no uh I'm not going to technically rule
that out but yes for the from the point
of view of what plausibly explains the
conversation that we are having you and
I are two human beings with a
disagreement interacting over the
Internet okay okay so I am saying the
same thing here is it you know is it
possible you know uh who knows am I a
schizophrenic who uh you know imagined
that there was something called covid
and that this is all happening in my
head I guess but I'm not going to spend
a whole lot of time worrying about that
what I think I've got is a lot of
information about how this system is
behaving none of it makes a wit of sense
it does appear to be rather completely I
mean
again you you decide that you get the
right to rule out the question of well
okay we've got two completely irrational
seemingly indifferent policies in two
different Realms right you don't want to
talk about why even though I'm sure you
have enough information to know it makes
no sense to administer mRNA vaccines to
children for covet right literally
haven't looked at the data I'm sorry I
don't have young children I'm a horrible
person for not being conversant in it
I'm sorry I looked my intuition is
what I'm telling you is you're living in
a phase of history in which we are
actually
contemplating mandating
of radical therapies that do not benefit
the individuals in question without
giving informed consent to them or in
this case their parents right we are
actually contemplating doing this
even though we know that the risks from
these things go heavily to the young for
multiple reasons that both because
they're more dangerous to the young and
because the young have longer lives
ahead of them and that the benefits go
in the opposite direction if there's any
benefit at all to these treatments they
do not go to young people and yet we're
doing it so my my point to you is
probably a couple hours work on your
part would reveal to you that we have
some crazy policy in motion that cannot
be explained epidemiologically or
medically or logically or any other way
that that policy is actually happening
that it's not something that happened
and has been slow to be reversed this is
more recent than the podcast you were
complaining about this is taking place
now you the problem is
the level of dysfunction exceeds normal
explanations and what I see you doing is
wanting to narrow down the question to
exactly one dysfunctional thing and then
stretch the hypotheses that you consider
reasonable to the extent that they can
cover that one thing and my point is
well that's not the context they exist
in you're existing in a moment where we
have somebody who's president who is
exhibiting Extreme cognitive decline
which means you and I don't know what's
President it means we've effectively
elected a party at best
that party is corrupt so we don't really
know what we've ushered into the
executive branch and we have all of
these policies that are emerging that
make no sense at all and do appear to
emerge from complete indifference to the
well-being of Americans
so I don't know why you want to limit
the discussion if I were in your shoes
because it's what we agreed to talk
about Brett it's what the pot it's what
this conversation was supposed to be
about right but you should have told me
if you wanted if you wanted to have a
whole conversation now I can get to the
why I consider you not a credible Source
on covet you want me to but first can I
finish these last two hypotheses because
you're going to like these you're gonna
like one of them because it's very
cynical it's just not as cynical as
yours okay you're gonna like this okay
here we go
so suppose somebody comes to you know
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff or whoever makes these decisions
and says uh
and says you know we're we're we're
suffering from more manpower loss than
we thought because of the vaccine thing
there's a lot of people who don't want
to take the vaccine we're having to you
know and then there may be people not
signing up because of that now one real
possibility it's a hypothesis worth
considering is that uh the general says
you know those are the kind of guys we
don't want in the military we want
people who follow orders just as well
without them that could well happen it's
a hypothesis it's possible holy moly
how well did you how well did you pay
attention to the podcast that you're
critiquing
did somebody say that
well my point was
the effect
whether it is intentional or not the
effect of booting all of the people who
ask questions and are inclined to say no
is to almost instantaneously create a
force that is much more likely to accept
immoral orders should they be handed
down yeah but you did not you did not
posit this as a motivation you did not
posit what I just posited as a
motivation you only entertained one
hypothesis on that podcast as far as I
recall so let me get on to my next one
I just articulated no no I certainly
entertained first of all there are two
podcasts with members of the military
who are now whistleblowers
I don't remember what was said what
happened after the one this was about
and the one I listened to but uh
nonetheless if you're saying that it has
not occurred to me and I have not said
that making a force that is more
compliant in the face of immoral orders
that that's not been on my mind and that
you're advancing I'm getting it I'm not
saying that I'm saying you did not pause
it
I'm not talking about moral or immoral
I'm not talking about uh generals who
say I don't want moral officers I'm
saying I mean look it's a widespread
cinnamon among Military Officers that
they want people who will
unquestioningly follow orders remember
one thing we do is take them to foreign
countries and say you have to kill this
guy just because he was born in this
other country so naturally however
you were talking about people who are in
one of very few professions where you
take an oath and officers who take that
oath upon becoming commissioned officers
in the military take an oath to defend
the Constitution not to follow orders
this is completely consistent with
Nuremberg the idea is their obligation
is to defend the Constitution against
enemies foreign and domestic and that
means immoral orders are not to be
followed
if you want to say that the motivation I
am suggesting could be at play in
hypothesis number three is an immoral
motivation fine have have you know have
fun with it I I am indifferent to that
question I'm just saying it is a common
desire in Military Officers that their
soldiers reliably obey orders so I can
imagine that being a reaction I mean
especially again there is this
bureaucratic inertia it's like oh man I
don't want to change the whole policy
they say but but but General they're
they're you know we're we we're we're
they're they're they're dropping out
he's like you know we don't want these
people in me final hypothesis is even
more cynical maybe you'll like this one
I I'm surprised it escaped your
attention and I don't I don't I don't
believe it has a high probability true
but but I can certainly imagine it is
that you come to a democratic
Administration
and you say
uh there's these soldiers dropping out
we're losing them and they say well you
know there's probably a correlation
between soldiers who don't want to get a
vaccine and soldiers who support Trump
and one concern we have uh in the wake
of uh January 6 and various other things
is that conceivably this country could
enter a crisis where there could be a
coup and you could want the uh the
military to be loyal to democratic
institutions uh or even more cynically
just say we don't want we don't want
team red we want team be as cynical as
you want but this is another uh this is
in my I have a whole spectrum of
cynicism from bureaucratic inertia to
the politics to the to the people not
wanting to admit policy error to them
wanting guys who just follow orders to
them wanting uh people who are not Trump
supporters fine you didn't entertain any
of these I think I think frankly all of
them are more plausible than the one you
entertained which by the way is the most
explosive one in a very incendiary
environment suggesting at least to read
what you said uh you in the obvious way
you'd think it's meant to be read that
there could be enemies in the state in
the administration you're now saying you
didn't quite mean that but no no no no
why didn't you do you do you agree that
you don't agree that my hypotheses are
worth considering only yours I didn't
say anything like that I do think that
the idea that a guy who just Advanced
the hypothesis that perhaps what's going
on is that the military brass was trying
to create a military force that it would
be less likely to Stage a coup
this is crazy that we have a corrupt
system in which our enemies no no you
mischaracterize what I said I didn't say
stage a coup I said and I and I wasn't
necessarily talking about officers I was
saying I can imagine people in the
administration I'm not even I mean I
don't think this is the case I'm just
saying that that in the list of
plausible hypotheses I think it's at
least more plausible than yours and it's
pretty cynical you should like it it is
a kind a conspiracy theory first of all
listen to yourself it's cynical
you maybe you should like it you're
calling me cynical I'm not cynical
right you you are characterizing me as a
cynical person who might like a
hypothesis on the basis that it is
cynical rather than on the basis that it
makes some kind of prediction that's
manifest in the world frankly that's
that's beneath you where I hope it is
no I think you have I think you have a
cynical view of the world I have a
pretty cynical view it's just it's just
not as dark as yours no I have a deeply
skeptical view of power I do not have a
cynical View
system is reflexive
okay so you're reflectively suspicious
not reflexively look I am suspicious of
our political apparatus after Decades of
watching it carefully but you know what
a cynical person would not have advanced
the unity 2020 concept
which was designed to put good people in
office in a place where they could
actually rescue the system from the top
which I think is frankly the only
plausible way to do it okay okay that is
not the move of a cynical person that is
the move of somebody who deeply loves
his country and does not want to see it
fail in this way
so you can take your your sense that I
am a cynical person and do with it what
you will but I am not a cynical person
now your hypothesis about what may have
been on the minds of military brass I
find
Preposterous the idea that that would
drive them which one the one that they
want people who will follow orders or or
no look I believe because the other one
I'm not attributing to military brass
well who are you attributing it to I'm
saying conceivably people in the
administration
a plan I
was saying
seeing mandate was a plan to get rid of
trump supports I'm saying if somebody
comes to them and says yeah we are
losing you know Fair number of soldiers
I can imagine in the current political
environment somebody's saying yeah just
as well man I mean if push comes to
shove you saw what happened January 6th
it push what comes to shove do we want
to attend to Trump supporters and of
course the military already at that
level at the you know uh kind of uh
enlisted man NGO level probably is uh or
enlisted whatever persons uh you know is
is probably pretty red anyway I again
I'm not saying that's the that would be
the motivation behind the Mandate I say
I can your question is why wasn't the
policy changed I'm saying there's a
whole ton of reasons the two most
plausible in my view are bureaucratic
inertia and assuming people share your
view of the policies downside not
wanting to admit error these things and
there's probably more and I just want to
emphasize yeah but there's only one that
you you you you virtually rule your
language virtually ruled out
some of these and and there's only one
you look because I think you should ask
why is that why is that just is a
pattern of incompetence and noise and
that's not the pattern that we see and
if you want to isolate this to one
question which is why our military
mandates maintained when civilian
mandates have largely been lifted if you
want to isolate it to that then you can
say well there are lots of hypotheses
but if you put it in the context of all
of the other bizarre things that have
happened surrounding covid and mandates
then you will understand that can't
possibly be the explanation there's too
much of it but what I really don't get
is you've already agreed to all of the
logical links necessary for my
hypothesis to definitely be in motion
now that doesn't mean it's the only
thing in motion because it's a question
of whether it's mutually exclusive but
you've agreed to a system in which
there's pay for play a system in which
we don't really even know what our
executive branch is because the
president can't really be playing that
role
so and you've agreed that our our
enemies will certainly have noticed the
pay for play nature of our system and
will certainly be utilizing it to some
extent so you have agreed that all of
the ingredients necessary for my
hypothesis to be at least relevant to
the question are you know not worth
arguing over
and yet you look at my putting those
dots together and saying well are we
being induced to harm ourselves because
something is driving that doesn't have
our well-being at heart you think that's
beyond the pale and frankly I don't see
the difference I'm just connecting the
dots that you and I both agree on no no
you're not putting together the dots
that I've agreed to do not turn this in
to a very plausible hypothesis and they
and they do not answer the question
logically wrong why are you say wrong
are you saying those dots point to your
hypothesis no and don't point to any of
the four here here I mentioned here is
the way you deal with this logically
okay Brett and Robert agree that there
is some degree of foreign influence over
our policy which is likely to be against
our interests and the question is to
what degree does that factor account for
the policy in question could be anywhere
from 0 0 to 1 right could be
is essentially negligible could be
entirely we should not be arguing over
whether or not that hypothesis is
plausible because you and I apparently
both believe it is the question is to
what degree
do I do I agree that yes there's foreign
influence of course but your hypothesis
is China of all no you didn't that I
tell you who it was and I said for the
sake of argument let's imagine it's
China I don't know if it's China how
would I know
well who else I mean well then you're
saying it's China not me
no I'm not I'm not saying it's anybody
who else you're suggesting that somebody
in China or Russia thought how we can
undermine the military I got an idea
mandatory vaccines I'm sure both of them
have mandatory vaccine policies of their
own so why would they think that
undermines the military Brad they're
probably about doing it
first of all do you deny that they're
both doing it I'll bet they are I
haven't looked it up wouldn't that be
bad for your hypothesis that one of the
major foreign powers sees mandatory
vaccines as a way to undermine our
military Readiness if it turns out that
they're doing that that would be really
do you agree that would really really
bad for your hypothesis right I don't
know
my understanding is that the Chinese
have not used any spike-based vaccine
they certainly are not using mRNA coded
in lipid nanoparticles so this is a very
different question now I don't pretend
to understand the inner workings of
China its authoritarianism its
governmental structure the tensions
within the administration but all I know
is that we have enemies they have money
and our system allows anybody with money
to buy in now
you seem to agree with those things you
seem to think China is the most likely
entity to be wielding this power
well yeah
campaign donations uh that's a primary
way but I really think you need to
sketch out the way this works because if
you're talking campaign donations then
you are ruling out everyone in the
Pentagon per se because they don't get
campaign donations no I don't you know
maybe I've misunderstood you because as
you say you're not a scientist
now
I am a Scientist I'm glad you're finally
agreeing with me I'm I'm glad I've
gotten you to a point where you where
you want to agree with me I'm not being
glib here okay I am a Scientist and
what's more I'm a biologist I work in
complex systems
if you say to me
well you're alleging that there is a
system in which some signal triggers
some pathway
and you would need to explain to me
where all of the molecules come from
that would be in that pathway before I
even believe that there is one I'll just
say nonsense right the fact is you can
infer that there's a pathway you can
know certain things about it and not
other things about it and you can find
out an awful lot about how it works
without having all of the details and
you're effectively holding me to a
standard where in order to say hey this
pattern of policy matches corruption by
an entity that does not wish us well
that in order to advance such a
hypothesis I would have to have all of
the details nailed down no sorry
logically that's not how it works
well when I have a hypothesis I try to
flesh it out and if I can't figure out
the exact mechanism by which it would
work I I don't cling to it the way
you're clinging to this one I fill in
the details or or I give up well you
have to at least have a conjectural
explanation of the way it would actually
work
I did I no you didn't for the sake of
argument let's imagine
it's China
okay and how do they do this they they
campaign donations get Biden to order
this or what
well I you know I don't think they can
donate to campaigns but the fact is
we're talking about clever people who
have huge quantities of resource at
their disposal so the question is how
can they purchase influence in a system
in which influences for sale
I don't think you or I have any doubt
that the Chinese were they to decide
they wanted to use money to influence
our political system that our political
system being open for business would
allow them to find a way to do that that
didn't make their fingerprints obvious
and then having done so that they would
be inclined to steer us not well not for
our well-being but they would be
inclined to steer us in a way that
worked for their interests
you know what I'll bet the Chinese think
uh uh I'll bet they think if you've got
a way you can give a test to soldiers to
find out which will willingly follow
orders and which will will ask
Troublesome questions and say I don't
want to do this and you can give them
the tests and the people who don't want
to follow the orders can be banished
from the military I think they'd say
that'll make your military stronger I'll
bet you anything so again this is a case
of just you keep assuming your view of
this whole thing is widely shared you
know even in the immigration or by the
Chinese and it's not it's a very
distinctive worldview you're gonna shout
anecdote okay but I was recently on a
plane
and I sat down next to a guy
I hadn't done anything to choose him as
a seat mate okay I just sat down next to
a guy he didn't know who I was and we
started talking turns out he's from a
multi-generation military family
currently he's in
and he's highly trained he's a mechanic
who works on aircraft and he didn't know
that I had done a podcast he didn't know
my political bent he didn't know
anything and I just started to ask him
about the conclusions from that podcast
and I said can you tell me about
readiness can you tell me about morale
and retention and he rolled his eyes and
he told me just how frightening the
situation was on the inside and in fact
even though he's from a multi-generation
military family he was looking to get
out right now I didn't he said it was
because of the vaccine mandate yes
because of the vaccine mandates and
because of the way people who didn't
want to take them have been treated
because there are no religious
exemptions because people are being
forced nobody wants to live in a
military like that this is bad for
morale well you know I just talked to a
guy who's a military veteran he said he
he doesn't think the military is ready
for a major war and when I ask him why
he talked about things like drug abuse
and and uh so there's there's lots of
problems in the military maybe that
aren't being addressed but uh that's a
separate problem okay I'm sure there is
a drug abuse problem that would happen
absent the problem with morale but
obviously the morale problem and the
drug abuse problem and the suicide
problem are all related
we are supposed to be able to fight two
simultaneous Wars that's what Readiness
is supposed to mean and we are degrading
that Readiness absurdly in a world where
it is becoming evident that we need it
more than ever
can I uh quickly get to I promise to
tell you
why I quit I decided to quit following
you as a credible Source on these issues
of covid vaccine so on uh you seem very
eager to tell me this although
um well it's it's real I think it's
related because it's another case where
I wonder how carefully uh you're
assessing the evidence
my guess would be that somebody who
wanted you to embarrass me has been
feeding you stuff and so yeah
I can prove that's not right I I've got
it on the record because I I commented
on it at the time okay let's hear it you
did this podcast with Steve Kirsch and
Robert Malone okay
and uh I came to doubt all three of you
Steve Kirsch happened at the beginning
he said I've written this down he said
uh he had had a carpet cleaner come into
his house who said quote I got the
Pfizer vaccine and I had a heart attack
two minutes later the guy said also my
wife she got the vaccine now her
handshakes when she holds a glass of
water and then curse said this
describing those two anecdotes he said
if it was really a safe vaccine then
what I just saw was impossible
impossible couldn't happen by chance not
right
it's a direct quote Brett I wrote it
down I'm reading it I just listened to
the podcast the word impossible is
obviously not right
he said Impossible on my podcast yeah
like why are you I guess I'm not a
credible source
so no well plus I mean he was there were
other things but no seriously I'm not
kidding this is serious stuff I I I you
know life is short so you can try the
guest on my podcast said one word that
was uncareful no no no I haven't gotten
to the point about you
okay you said and this is the part I
commented at the time honest the time as
I will explain
you said quote the data suggests that
the prophylactic Ivermectin is something
like 100 effective in preventing people
from Contracting covid when taken
properly
then you later said in the podcast the
Argentina study which suggests 100
effectiveness of ivermectin I went and
Googled the Argentina study and here is
a sentence from the abstract
the experimental group received
Ivermectin orally two tablets of six
milligram every seven days and Iota
carrageenan six sprays per day it's a
nasal spray for four weeks this was in
the in the abstract you didn't have to
go far to find this sentence what
they're saying is there were two
separate treatments applied to everyone
in the treatment group and what that
means and what that means is you cannot
infer anything with great confidence
about either of them because because the
one the nasal spray had been shown to be
affected with other respiratory illness
and you were looking at this all you had
to do is read the abstract to get to
this and saying it's 100 Effectiveness
now uh I went on my podcast and said to
I was talking to Mickey cows I said you
know Brett Weinstein said this thing I
went and read the abstract he's clearly
off base and Mickey said you sure I mean
I don't that seems like a pretty obvious
error I said go read the paper now Weeks
Later
you I don't know how word got to you
that you should reread the paper I think
you to your credit
said I shouldn't have said that but my
question is how motivated must your
reasoning have been if if reading every
sentence in the abstract would have
precluded your saying what you said on
that podcast that's when I quit thinking
of you is credible
all right
you have
settled I believe on a hypothesis that
the combination of carrageenan and
Ivermectin might have been essentially a
hundred percent effective and that money
I mean the study showed High
effectiveness of the tree in the
treatment group absolutely yes yes
and so the error you're concerned about
is that I alighted the use of
carrageenan in a protocol that might
have been a hundred percent effective or
nearly so
that's what you're concerned about not
that the public health authority didn't
notice that a combination of carrageenan
and Ivermectin might be nearly 100
effective here's what I'm saying Brett
what here's what I'm saying
if I do a study where I give everyone in
the treatment group both ibuprofen and
aspirin and they all say their headaches
went away and and and nobody in the
other group does and I come back and say
this study shows that aspirin is a
hundred percent effective that is an
obvious fallacy you disagree no look we
we agree that I should have said a
combination of carrageenan and
Ivermectin appears to be near 100
effective that's what I should have said
okay I mean that's an important it's an
important point of course which is why I
corrected it now it happens
I don't know if you know the full
history of what went down with this
study do you
no it doesn't matter for purpose the
point of making but I'm happy to hear
what went down it does matter
the fact is concerns were raised about
this study right
I became concerned about it and I
pursued the data from the study I
contacted the studies author and I said
can I look at the data set and he
initially told me that I could and then
I couldn't get it from him and after a
month of trying to get the data set to
look at it I told my audience I said
look
this study cannot be replicated and it
should be given zero evidentiary weight
I believe the study took place I believe
it did show high Effectiveness and I do
not believe that carrageenan was the
driving Factor but it doesn't matter
were there a combination of two safe
drugs that we could administer that
would prevent covid it would have
avoided a tremendous amount of harm and
disruption to our system so that would
be the error but at the point that that
system that study could not be
demonstrated to have taken place and
given that result because the data set
was not provided
I said it takes zero evidentiary weight
so that's the right thing well that
part's commendable but it's unrelated to
what I just said no I've acknowledged I
have acknowledged that in a live
discussion with two other people I said
Ivermectin when what I should have said
was Ivermectin plus Kerry gainan but had
that been the issue then we're talking
about a minor foul where I am
referencing a study that shows 100
Effectiveness or nearly so and it's two
things that are safe and could be
administered to everybody the error is
that we didn't pay attention to that
signal
right that may be an error you may be
right but my point is this is not a slip
of the tongue a you said it twice what
clearly happened well I don't know you
tell me what happened all you had to do
is read the abstract to know that you
cannot make a confident inference about
either of these things and and and yet
you you made one and look again really I
really acknowledge that okay but what do
you think was at work why why you know
confirmation bias uh comes out of
emotion it's it's because you feel
strongly committed to a hypothesis that
you ignore a quali uh you know evidence
that's either contradictory or or adds
Nuance or whatever you would you you it
seems like you didn't even see this part
of the sentence in the abstract and and
I'm just asking of course why do you
think you were socially motivated but
this wasn't the only study that said
Ivermectin was was useful this was one
of multiple studies that said that I
think it's yeah it was on my mind and I
made a linguistic error and is it you
said yes however which suggests 100
Effectiveness I don't wanna you know I
don't wanna seem like I'm obsessed but
you do uh I I don't agree that this is a
minor foul I'm sorry I mean you've
gotten a podcast with a big audience and
you you you went and told them you had
evidence it was 100 effective and you
didn't and let me ask you this okay so
on my podcast I corrected my error Weeks
Later yeah fine I'm not saying it was
intentional
you you should be commended for
correcting it but but what I'm asking so
we're looking we're looking for
scientists who don't make errors
I'm looking for people who speak about
this subject carefully and assess the
evidence carefully and I and and I'm
just telling you when I got off the boat
when I I look I listened to the whole
podcast at that point I was saying I
think the jury is out on Ivermectin I
was saying it publicly and I still don't
I I don't I'm you know I don't have
strong views even today I haven't paid
much attention but you should you should
pay attention I promise it's another
story that will tell you something is
afoot here that makes no sense
uh could be but but again that would not
be related to the military Readiness
thing we came to talk about the the uh
and look maybe people will say I'm
making a mount out of well I'm just
explaining why
I I've made a good faith effort to
listen to the people you had assembled
and uh probably time does not permit us
to get into Robert Malone but I've
written a piece called as Robert Malone
crazy in the non-zero newsletter people
can Google it and and he he was prone to
a kind of conspiracy theorizing which I
describe in that piece very much well
hypothesizing sorry very much like yours
in the sense that
plain old the way bureaucrat
bureaucracies work
explain the evidence he was citing uh
and he didn't entertain that hypothesis
and and uh
you know so
um
that's uh
now I would say well no look
people who have spoken out openly on
this subject people with expertise who
have spoken out openly have faced an
onslaught of propaganda and stigma and
character assassination okay we now know
that this has flowed through the tech
platforms that it has been in
coordination with the executive branch I
don't think you're in a good position to
judge how people faced with that have
have done because frankly I don't think
they're even in a good position to know
what was true and what was propaganda
that you've fallen for
um
none of us can ever be completely sure
about this stuff no I don't I don't know
what you're referring to
I'm referring to a campaign to
stigmatize to remove credentials from to
Usher out of the Public Square people
who raised very legitimate concerns
about our covid policy I agree that this
is a problem generically and and in
areas where
no because I mean it's true in other
areas it's true with foreign policy it's
true right now uh with uh you know
people who who say that NATO expansion
may have had something to do uh may have
raised the chances of an invasion of
Ukraine being called Putin apologists or
Pro Putin or whatever I I and I'm not
denying I am not a political bickering I
am talking about the exactly Branch
targeting citizens and portraying them
as spreading Miss Mal and disinformation
when that is in fact not what they were
doing I agree that the net has been cast
too wide uh in this uh look I don't
doubt that if you showed me particular
cases of people being de-platformed on
this very issue I would say that wasn't
Justified I am not a big defender of
de-platforming and uh look I agree the
hunter Biden laptop was was a case of
that and uh even though at the time I
was I was kind of you know I was kind of
hoping the story would go away because I
I didn't want Trump elected but I agree
that there was uh there was unwarranted
speech policing and uh it happens in
foreign policy I don't doubt that it
happens in this realm at all it's not
speech policing people and we had the
New York Post
silenced on a legitimate news story
about an intimate family connection of
the person being elected president
why are we arguing this I mean strictly
we are arguing this point because and
frankly I think it's the theme of this
entire podcast
you want to zero in on individual issues
and give a particular perspective when
those issues exist together in a context
that Demands a larger explanation
uh
well I I agree that some of them are
interrelated now strictly speaking the
post wasn't silenced it was kicked off
of social this post was not allowed on
social media platforms the post
publisher what I wanted to post
published but uh but I agree that the
policing was unwarranted uh and I do
think unwarranted you're talking about
intervention in an election you're
talking about a country that in its
first amendment enshrines the ability to
discuss things openly and you are
talking about
um
actions
which frankly are unconscionable
journalistically
the post had a right to that story
escalated my adjectives from unwarranted
and tell me when I've gotten high enough
villainous
inexcusable indefensible inimical to the
principles on which our country was
founded tell me what tell me when to
stop I mean I don't know why you're
arguing with me about this well I'm
arguing with you about it because it was
consequential this was a historic breach
it might have affected the election
that is why it was silenced yeah
there is a connection I think among all
of these things so we've got
evidence of corruption in the family of
the president surrounding Ukraine
we have Tech Giants coordinating with
the executive branch and silencing a
newspaper that is in possession of a
legitimate news story how Un-American
would this have to get
I thought I just said an immaculative
principle now which this country
sounding by the way the question the
strength of the evidence is another
question that I'm not addressing I I
just think it the the uh they should not
try to suppress that these things were
found on Hunter Hunter Biden's laptop
whatever you think whatever you want to
make of them yeah that's that's all well
and good two years down the road but the
fact is a some of us were targeted for
talking about this at the time maybe you
were one of them but targeted to talk
about it the fact is Americans should
not be targeted for talking about things
even if they turn out not to be true the
way we find out if they're true is we
talk about them we don't silence each
other this has this has been the nature
of policy surrounding covid from the
get-go we are not allowed to talk about
certain things right many of us were
demonized for talking about the
connection of this virus to the lab in
Wuhan right
that was absurd the fact is this is a
scientific question And scientists were
talking about it and they were silenced
by a political entity what political
entity we don't know we have a president
who isn't really president I don't
understand why that doesn't bother you
more
who said it didn't bother me Brett where
is this coming from
listening to what I'm saying who came
after me for saying something highly
unusual is going on with our executive
branch where our executive branch is
doing things that don't appear to be in
our interest but you seem to just blow
by the fact that our executive branch
isn't even built in the way the founders
of the nation decided it should be what
is President the Democratic Party
I've already said I'm very disconcerted
by the cognitive status of our president
yes but you're not connecting these two
dots they're right next to each other
you've got an executive branch whose
nature you don't know and you've got
policy coming from it that makes no
sense
now the question when you say you you're
the one who's saying it makes no sense I
mean that's and and you're assuming that
view is rightly you are telling me you
are telling me that incompetence
and the sluggishness of bureaucracy are
as good an explanation for it making no
sense as my hypothesis that is not
either of us saying actually the policy
makes sense I'm saying if I grant you
your premise that it makes no sense
I don't even know what discussion we're
having then Robert you really think this
problem
why would you mandate why would you
mandate a treatment that doesn't block
transmission to people who are in
general young enough that they won't get
any benefit for it why would you do it
I have explained my view of why the
policy was initially implemented it's
using imminently plausible uh and and
and not not really shouldn't be that
controversial it's so obvious uh
uh the the question I think you're
asking is why wasn't the policy
rescinded I have suggested that there
are a number of hypotheses that are
significantly more plausible than yours
and yet you are you you did not even
entertain them you leap to the darkest
most incendiary most conspiratorial on
the entire spectrum of hypotheses and
I'm saying that's not good science
that's bad science no I'm saying it
doesn't mean your hypothesis has no
chance of being true it means you are
not looking at things in a balanced way
no this is coming from you zeroing in on
one issue in isolation rather than
looking at a context in which policy
after policy looks like this like the
vaccinating of children at the behest of
the executive branch after we know that
this thing doesn't block transmission
that makes no sense either
I'm telling you the only way you get
there is indifference to the well-being
of Americans that's the floor
this is this is a new policy this is not
an entrenched policy this is a new
policy I just don't know enough to argue
about this I'm sorry I wish I did I
fully accept that you don't know but my
point is you are drawing conclusions
that require you not to know
wait you're saying that I've chosen not
to know about this so that I can argue
with you about the military or what are
you saying that when you have this
number of Highly unusual decisions
happening at once and you have decided
to focus in on one and then say well I'm
not responsible for the others then the
point is if the others make a consistent
pattern with the one that you are
defending as very probably the result of
much more ordinary phenomena that that
is you making an error not recognizing
something highly unusual has taken place
here
we we are in a situation in which the
policy emanating from our executive
branch
does not make any sense from the point
of view of even an inept attempt to
protect Americans
that's a problem and that problem may
require you to Branch out and look
further than you have looked so far
I I think evaluating your hypothesis uh
doesn't doesn't require more than I
posited I mean it would if you were like
see the thing is the two are not even
connected in your mind in a grand
conspiracy hypothesis you're not saying
that Chinese are trying to get vaccines
into the schools I assume and you
haven't said that big Pharma is trying
to get vaccines into the military so
it's not like there's even a really deep
organic Connection in your own mind no
between these except that you're saying
that's America there is a deep
connection Robert and it's something
I've been focused on for decades it is
the absolute Corruption of our system
which has now reached a point where
policy cannot even be rationalized now
do I believe that you know whatever
entity it is that decided to maintain
those mandates in the military is
exactly the same as that which decided
to inflict these so-called vaccines on
children in order for them to get
educated no my guess would be that the
latter is about Pharma and frankly about
liability protection which comes from
putting these things on the childhood
vaccine schedule and the that the former
is about potentially unhooking our
Readiness because something doesn't care
about it or is actively interested in
doing so but I don't know I'm not
telling you I'm not on the inside of
this corruption racket but I can tell
you that what has happened is a system
that had some corruption has now become
completely corrupt and what that has
resulted in is something with no
institutions that function right no
newspaper no platform no University none
of these things work neither of our
parties represents
no no institutions that function
is the kind of hyperbole I've heard from
you in other contexts I think if you
reflected on it you'd say well okay that
what I mean is they're pretty damn
dysfunctional most of them some of them
less so blah blah blah but I mean you do
that you're inclined to do that and so
I'm curious I mean obviously we could
come up with some tiny institutions what
I mean to say is no institution above
some threshold size but what
institutions are you talking about
well I mean I see you know I I've I've
been in journalism a long time and and
I'm and I'm uh disappointed by the
current state uh of the major media but
I wouldn't say they're not functioning I
would say
uh they've never been perfect they've
never been perfectly objective
uh and they are significantly less so
now and the Norms are changing on the
other hand the Norms are moving to a
kind of Norm that prevailed in
journalism a long time ago in our
Republic where most media Outlets were
partisan apparently that's where we're
headed it doesn't it doesn't I mean it
may be doesn't mean that they're not
functioning they're functioning
differently and you know this this is
this is preposterous
just as a journalist argue that the fact
that our our journalistic landscape has
broken out in a a hemorrhage of partisan
politics is not evidence of dysfunction
now it's evidence of dysfunction you
said they're not functioning
there's always been a degree of
dysfunction in some respects there's
more now listen
um I I think I've made my my view on
your military Readiness hypothesis
pretty clear I said to you before
uh
do you you know I well first I said do
you want uh could I run this on my
podcast and understandably you're
ambivalent uh and you suggested a part
two where you come on my podcast and I'd
be happy to do that and you know what I
if you don't want to talk about this
stuff that's fine too we have a lot of
things we can talk about we can talk
about just this last part how
dysfunctional is the information
processing system we can talk about
evolutionary biology I have questions
about your your differences with Richard
Dawkins on memes and uh the extended
phenotype I'm happy to talk about
anything uh if you want to come to my
podcast and I'm happy to stick around
and and and and answer
fill in any blanks you feel are not
filled in in this conversation well I
mean I must say you're leaving me with
uh a big mystery about
how your mind works right that's what
we'll solve on my podcast I actually
want to solve anything it seems to me
that you you are starting with a
perspective and you are bending over
backwards to rescue it and part of what
you're doing is being hyper focused and
deciding to exclude large areas of
territory and then you're making claims
like well you're obviously uh something
wrong with your perspective if you think
no institutions are functional and I say
what institutions are functional and you
say well journalism for example might
you know have its problems but it's not
as if it's dysfunctional and then you go
on to describe its dysfunction and then
you give me crap over the distinction
between uh what was it malfunctioning
and dysfunction I mean what is going on
Robert
what's with you
no I I just said for you to say no
institutions are functioning seems to me
hyperbolic well that's why I asked you
name one that is and you came up with
journalism and then you described why
it's not functioning
you know I think uh I know the
shortcomings you would point to in the
educational system for example sure
it's functioning we are miseducating
people we are telling them that there
aren't two Sexes we are telling them
that two plus two does not necessarily
equal four we are beginning to erode the
agreement that we had that pedophilia is
bad yes it's [ __ ] up actually we're
not telling him two plus two doesn't
equal four that's my point I mean
there's a lot of good mathematical
education going on it's not
dysfunctional no no no no no no no you
want to talk about all this
good mathematical education going on but
the fact is if we are actively
miseducating people if we are taking
things that we know and pretending they
aren't if we are failing to allow a
discussion of whether or not these
particular so-called vaccines are safe
whether or not there is a a increase in
excess deaths in the aftermath of the
vaccination campaign whether or not
there is countervailing evidence on the
global warming consensus if we're not
talking about these things then these
aren't truth seeking entities the
universities are not functioning they
are not educating so you you can just
keep naming these empty shells and you
can say Well they're not perfect but
they are functioning yeah all right the
universities are collecting tuition they
have classrooms people go to them they
hear lectures that's not functioning
functioning involves educating it
involves a net increase in the capacity
of students to think and we are not
doing that I know I've been a professor
I've seen it up close
you're not teaching at a typical
University but uh you know it was one of
the more out there fringy places
whatever it was that made my institution
non-typical has now spread to the rest
of them not that many
I'll tell you I gave a talk at Marist
College in New York only a few years ago
it's very different you know first of
all what you're saying was so unusual in
my college was happening up till 2017.
okay so you gave a talk a few years ago
at a small College which you think is an
indication that that college is now
still functioning how would you know
this stuff was far enough along that I
said to the president of of the college
like
I don't see any woke stuff and he said
yeah it's like there's there's a lot of
places that are like that so so the woke
stuff was out there and he's like
yeah this is just you know there's a lot
of a lot of colleges like that was his
view anyway so many years ago podcast
what some years ago
well I mean like like three even the
rate given the rate at which this is
moving I don't understand why you're
taking a data point from several years
ago as indicative of anything
okay look I gotta go I I gotta get my
newsletter out um do you do how about
this podcast invitation that I'm hoping
you'll graciously accept I don't see an
appointment
Brett you know what people are gonna say
I do
you're gonna say you're afraid
you think I'm afraid I didn't say that I
said people are naturally going to say
it if you're not willing to accept an
invitation
you know I want to encourage them to say
that and if they say it I will defend
your honor I'll say gosh darn it I think
Brett is just busy even though before
this podcast he said he'd be happy to
come on on my podcast you know you have
said
multiple insulting things here right you
have told me about the point at which
you stopped taking my perspective
seriously
right now I didn't jump but
that way people can judge it for
themselves but why would I be coming on
your podcast I didn't put it that way I
said like life is short you're trying to
get to the bottom of this covet thing
you you know you got to figure out well
who are you going to pay attention to
and I I'm maybe I'm too finicky but you
and this guy Steve Kirsch both said
things on your podcast that made me
think well I I think when somebody's a
little more careful in what they say
than that I'm sorry if you can judge
whether I'm crazy
I'm not careful enough or I am careful
enough
you want to have it both those are those
are uh seem to me to yeah that pretty
much exhausts the possibilities right
and so you've said I'm not careful
enough and then here you are wanting me
on your podcast
well we don't have to talk about that
I'm very interested in your ideas about
Evolution uh we can talk about the state
of media but look it's up to you
you know let people say what they will
yep I will not encourage it I'll
discourage it
I will say don't say that about Brett
you know
there's something odd about you and I
can't figure out what it is you're a
little late to that realization Perhaps
Perhaps but nonetheless I think if
people listen back through this podcast
they will understand that at some level
you're willing to see lots of the pieces
of the puzzle can't accuse you of not
seeing them but you're not willing to
connect the dots and
uh I really think you owe it to your
audience to do so I predict that
different people will see different
things and most of the regular listeners
to your podcast will have an unfavorable
view of me and this is the America we
live in
um and you know where it's it's
tribalized and the different you know
it's part of the problem you're
describing you have these different
media Outlets that have the perspective
you don't have anything like One-Stop
shopping if you're trying to get it the
truth so you have to like try to try to
get Divergent perspectives which I do I
listen to during the Trump years I
listened to Steve band's podcast
religiously
now I listen to these like pro-russia
Invasion guys to get that side of the
story
um you do what you can but unfortunately
what's going to happen is that people
who went into this with my perspective
are going to say that that I was right
and people who yours are going to say I
was wrong and they're probably on both
sides they're going to say we're
horrible human beings
I don't think you're a horrible human
being I I I think you you we all do
motivated reasoning this was a big theme
in my book the moral animal
uh and uh
and and I I you know and and and he who
is without sin should should uh cast the
first stone so I'm not going to cast the
first down second
all right well Robert it's been an
interesting ride so no the answer is no
on the podcast
I I haven't decided but I think the
answer should be no because frankly what
we've done here is we've butted heads I
think people can get a pretty good sense
of where each of us are coming from and
I'm not sure
why I would participate in a podcast for
somebody who has decided on the basis of
uh an error which I have acknowledged
and corrected without anyone needing to
tell me to do it uh I'm not sure why
such a person would go on a podcast with
somebody who is deciding to I'm not
saying it discredits everything you said
I'm saying it's it's why I decided Well
you know I'll
I'll try to look for people who face who
who assess the evidence more carefully
that was my call
life is short we pick our sources my
point is you're being inconsistent
because you said well here's why I
decided that but then hey why don't you
come on my podcast that seems bizarre to
me Brett that's not bizarre come on
there's no contradiction there I I I
entertain all podcasts I'm like look
I've had everything from neocons I have
my podcast has like the broadest range
everything from Brett Stevens David from
Bill Crystal neocons to Aaron matte Max
Blumenthal Gray Zone there's I don't
think there's any other podcast that can
say that that's not the question the
question is is it productive
I think so
I think I think we need to you don't
believe we need to hear all views even
once we disagree with sharply I don't
believe we need to hear all views I
believe we need to hear many views but
what I don't dig is your uh blanket
statements about credibility where I
lost it but uh hey let's talk because we
can we've got other topics it doesn't
really work like that so okay will you
at least consult with Heather because
she got my tweet right she interpreted
my tweet correctly
um well maybe she'll watch this and find
me Charming you never know
perhaps in any case Robert
um I'm going to recommend that people
check out your book non-zero I still
think it's a great book I appreciate
that well worth well worth the reading
uh I wish I could say it had been a
pleasure talking but I think it is uh
I've enjoyed it
all right well sorry all right
talk to you later
foreign
[Music]